the white house changes come as
Republicans try to iron out a possible
repeal bill to the affordable care act
but that continues to be mired in delays
for more on where things stand we turn
to turn to CBS News political director
Steve shigera Steve good morning morning
what exactly are the Republicans gonna
be voting on that's a very good even
though they don't know and Senate
Republicans are running around Capitol
Hill this week trying to figure that out
there are a couple of choices that Mitch
McConnell has laid out there's one
choice which is a repeal and replace
bill which would which doesn't have
enough support to get it to the floor
for a vote and then he said well if we
can't do that then maybe we'll vote on
just a repeal bill something that the
Senate passed to in 2015 but again that
is now running into resistance from
Senate Republicans why are they having
so many problems right now
well I think there's a couple of reasons
one first of all is the tide has turned
on polling if you look at the last seven
years of polling on Obamacare Americans
had they just approved of Obamacare
until President Trump became president
and then all of a sudden the polls
changed when it might be taken away well
that's right
and so now these Republicans go home
during their breaks and they listen to
their constituents and people aren't
happy about the idea of Obamacare going
away and so they're hearing it from them
and they're getting cold feet now did
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell I
mean he's got a lot of experience in
handling these things but do you think
he miscalculated the differences within
his own party here well if he did he
shouldn't have because we have known for
years of all the times that Republicans
have repealed or voted to repeal
Obamacare they have never been able to
agree on the replacement right and so
that's where they find themselves we saw
the House wrestling with this earlier
this year and now we see the Senate so
it shouldn't have been a surprise to him
it got almost more difficult the Senate
parliamentarian said the bird rule has
been violated with some of the
provisions can you explain that yes so
the bill that is the repeal and replace
bill it was looked at by the Senate
parliamentarian and there are provisions
in there that they say needs 60 votes
they've been trying to get this repeal
and replace bill through with 51 votes
they haven't even been able to do that
right they can't even get 51 votes there
are provisions and there are some pretty
key provisions in there that would need
60 votes the parliamentarian says they
ruled on that
yesterday okay so the Senators who were
trying to figure out what's going on
moving forward are now discovering that
good chunk of this bill one of the bills
that they're considering is is probably
not ever gonna be voted on some of those
things that has to do with Planned
Parenthood a lot of those things that
have been under attack Parenthood and
Medicaid right yeah so you take it out
and then it's a completely it's a
completely different bill than what
they've already been debating so
Democrats have had a United funds or
united front against the repeal of
Obamacare obviously there's been some
talk of actually trying to work with
Democrats is is that real I I just I
know people are talking about it I just
don't see where it happens I don't see
where Republicans come to the table with
Democrats and say sure we're gonna sit
down with you because it's in our
political interest to sit down with you
I think it's in their political interest
to not there's their voters their base
set it says repeal Obamacare sitting
down with Democrats does not get there
you talk about that base this is what
they campaigned upon the president
campaigned upon so if nothing gets past
a what's the impact in future elections
but where do they go that's a very good
question so conservatives and
conservative groups will be very upset
if they don't repeal Obamacare and so
this could be a problem for those who
are running for re-election next year
they may find themselves running in
primaries against other Republicans more
conservative Republicans saying you did
not keep your promise to repeal
Obamacare all right Stevie sugarless
thanks for being with us this morning